well shania twain is celebrating two big
milestones this year
later this month she'll turn 55 and this
year also marks
the 25th anniversary of her breakthrough
album the woman in me
anchored by huge hits like whose bed
have your boots been
under and any man of mine her sophomore
album sold
12 million in the us alone and 20
million around the world
and this october 2nd you can hear it
again for the first time
with the special diamond edition yes and
it's certainly redefined country music
and it definitely changed nia twain's
life forever
what was the first splurge you had
uh you know what i did when i first
started making
money that was more than just scraping
by was
go to the grocery store and
not need to use coupons
and buy non-bruised apples
and not overripe bananas
you know stuff like that just getting to
the cash register
and knowing that i was going to be able
to afford it and not have to put things
back
coolest feeling
[Music]
you know it was so cool to see you and
any man of mine
that video came out and i thought whoa i
want to be shania
and then that mid-drift causing all that
stir
did you realize the impact that video
was going to have
no i could never have imagined the
impact that any of this was going to
have
i was always very shy about my body so i
made a point of being brawless
and you were i was gonna ask you you are
braless in it
i'm braless in the brown slip grass i'm
braless
in whose bed of your boots been under in
the red dress and these were
no one just for me they were statements
to myself
you know because i had gone from
strapping my boobs down
so that i could play football with with
with the guys
and i'm thinking ah enough with this
strapping down
just take the bra off and
[Music]
and embrace yourself
but shania's not done making music
moments to remember
to work with orville peck you listen to
his voice it's so iconic his
fashion is iconic he's breaking barriers
the way you are he's openly gay what
does it mean that a canadian is actually
making changes in the industry
like he's getting out there with courage
and representing definite
originality and not afraid to do it he's
so unique his voice is unique and rich
and
beautiful tonally and he's super styled
[Music]
and your birth is coming up is there
anything on your wish list that you
haven't done yet
for my birthday maybe i will ride go
fareback riding on the horse
that would be a good thing that's a gift
to myself i love
that that's so good if i do yeah if i
manage it i'll
i'll video it